I'm super excited to be here I think I
took 472 like seven times both because
it was a good easy credit but mostly
because it was really great to just see
like so many people who had gone through
it had so much experience and to to get
to share in that throughout this I
really encourage or really invite all of
us to stay present and engaged if you
can in the sense of like if you're bored
look bored if you're excited about what
I'm saying look excited because I have
you know hours and hours of stuff I
could share with you and that'll help me
calibrate to making sure you're getting
the most out of this that you can be in
fact before we get started you guys
probably had classes all day and I've
been doing things all day invite you to
just take one moment in just maybe
exhale and then take a collective inhale
and exhale just come into the space
together I feel very privileged and
grateful for the fact that I feel like I
have a deep deep sense of calling and
purpose and passion I'm working on
technology and helping to build this
product in this company and it feels
like not it almost feels like I'm not
building it but like there is something
that's coming through me that wants to
be expressed in the world something that
will help potentially make the make
human beings happier reduce suffering
make the world a more not only a happier
but a more interesting place and it's
comes from a place of really
understanding sort of the the
connectedness of the world and the ways
in which I see you the possibility for
us to come together and really do great
things together this big collaborative
endeavor so I want to want to talk today
first of all about about my my own
journey in coming to that and coming to
this place in my life talk about a big
vision for Humanity that I hope will be
or inspiring to all you and that sort of
can encompass a lot of other visions as
well as how we're manifesting some of
that specifically in a sauna and then in
the second half will look at some some
values some leadership tactics and some
ways of managing your own psychology
that i have found invaluable in lead
teams that have these big ambitious
missions at all the different companies
that the Tina mentioned so practical
advice for you as you execute on your
own big visions or joint other people's
big visions so starting with my journey
I'll start wearing i was 10 i got my
first computer and i was immediately
fascinated by this this magical box it
was so incredible to me that i could i
started writing little games that i
could give to friends on floppy disks
and it occurred to me even really early
on that I was writing code once but then
all of these different people throughout
throughout the my middle school we're
getting to enjoy the benefits of that
and get to play this game I didn't have
the word leverage at the time but that
was a really great taste of that
experience and as I grew up I wanted to
give bigger gifts to more people with
even more leverage I eventually I ended
up at Stanford where I was in the
Mayfield Fellows Program which honestly
that in this course like really were
quite life-changing for me I came into
Stanford very much a not particularly
socialized very nerdy heady person and
being at Stanford and especially these
courses really helped me understand that
the benefits of being able to work in
the much more in some ways complex juicy
space of individual human interactions
and how to think about teams how to lead
teams little sad how little of my job
these days involves coding and
engineering but on the plus side I get
to enjoy this rich fruitful life of
helping people who are who are doing
that come together and do really big
things in the world things much bigger
than I'd be able to do as an individual
after that I went to Google I left
Stanford a little early which I have
some mixed feelings about but Google was
really taking off and it was a really
exciting place to be interestingly most
of the bigger projects that I worked on
were total abject failures and and some
one didn't even see the light of day but
I managed to I realized in hindsight
make make a bunch of little steps along
the way so one for example was at some
point Google was working on a standalone
I am client for people that you could
goes like AOL Instant Messenger and I
asked at some point well why don't we
just put it put that inside of gmail
because people are already chatting or
people already doing communication
inside of gmail when we just add a a
real-time component and my boss at the
time said oh yeah we thought of that and
it's impossible I was like really it's
impossible to do chat inside of a
browser he's like yep we looked into it
totally impossible like in fact I'll bet
you that he'll never be done inside a
browser and so I went home that night
wrote it or wrote a very simple version
of chat showed it to the next morning
and the chat inside of gmail project
started so the lesson there of course is
when people tell you something's
impossible be very skeptical chat also
worked on a bunch of early versions of
Google Drive contributing to a bunch of
things that are inside this interface as
well as actually a full-blown version of
pretty much the Google Drive product
that exists today though for a bunch of
difficulties or navigating the
organization wasn't able to ship that
after that I went to Facebook where went
from product management engineering
management and tech leading and did a
bunch of things were really exciting to
me including Facebook pages which was a
really cool way to allow non-human
entities to also participate in the
social graph and then my hackathon
project was the like button which I
helped lead the development of as well
and that came out of this observation
that people were using things like wall
posts and comments to express
affirmation and positivity and I it
dawned on me i was like what if we could
make it easier what if we couldn't make
it so that the effort required was so
low and eventually realized the lowest
effort possible would be one click what
if we can make it super easy for people
to share that kind of positivity with
each other and that led to the the
design of the like button to this day
the number one most requested feature
that Facebook gets is the dislike button
which is funny to me because it really
misses the point of the exercise and
we're trying to encourage and actually
design the infrastructure in the social
graph in a in a way that is opinionated
in a way that prefers a world in which
we help each other
help affirm each other rather than a
world in which we tear each other down
so that's why there is a like and not a
dislike book I'll talk in a minute about
how we started this but then went on to
start a sauna which at this point we're
at 40 people and really really proud of
where we've gotten so far it has become
this communication and coordination
system that for a lot of companies
replaces the majority of their email we
have tons of different tech companies
who rely on the sauna is a core backbone
of what they do hue also have companies
all sorts of other industries that
they're using it as this is this deep
improvement to the way they communicate
we will talk about how the impact that
it's had on their ability to accomplish
their missions in life and achieve their
visions has just been so powerful and
for me that's the most gratifying thing
of all so that's a little bit about my
background but probably the most
interesting thing for me in terms of for
me what is the source of all passion of
all of my passion pretty much every
single day I wake up and then multiple
times throughout the day have this
moment of complete and utter shock and
awe and joy that we are alive very easy
to get distracted by the day today and
have to make rush to this meeting or
this class or follow this commitment or
something but how unbelievably crazy is
it but there is a universe at all or
that within that universe we are these
sentient little monkey beings that are
tooling around and with first-person
perspective interacting with each other
I love the universe so deeply with all
my heart and I'm so inspired by this
impossibly rare you couldn't even
compute the probability there's an
impossibly rare gift of being incarnate
and alive and on top of that it's finite
where we only get to experience this for
a short period of time and that has
inspired me to just want to live every
single day to the fullest and to really
enjoy this this being as much as I
possibly can
and in some ways that early on led me to
almost almost a sort of heat vism I was
like I'm in this for me I got I'm going
to consume as much resources as I
possibly can get as much out of this
this crazy experience that I'm having as
I possibly can and what I found and
that's pretty much how I lived for about
20 years until I started to realize that
it was not working you'd think like the
shortest path from here to living life
to the fullest would be try to take
everything you can but it turned out
that it was really a miserable failure
pretty much over and over again and as
I've done more personal growth done more
introspection thought more about it and
just sort of studied the nature of man
as a social animal I realized that we're
just that's not how we achieve that kind
of deep satisfaction enjoy the way we
achieve it is ironically by giving of
ourselves and i don't mean giving of
yourselves all day all the time I kind
of think of it like there's an inhale
and there's an exhale there's i spend
about half my top half of my life being
hedonist about half of my life
contributing back giving back trying to
do everything i can to help others to
show love to manifest love in the world
and to try to reduce suffering and
create joy and explore consciousness but
in partnership with all sentient beings
and in the course of that of that I've
started to just think more and more
about what what are the most leveraged
ways I can actually have this impact if
I'm going to take this sort of
Bodhisattva vow and dedicate myself
wholeheartedly you know I could go and
build houses for people like there's all
sorts of things you sort of think of as
philanthropic but what I realized is
that you know I could build one person a
house and that would be satisfying to
them and satisfying to me I get to look
them in the eye but technology has been
this huge game changer for our ability
to have impact that's such an enormous
scale I mean the idea of even like
contributing one feature to google
search in the way that helps people gain
more access to knowledge which in turn
allows them to do important things and
turn allows them to solve world problems
is is in some ways so much more exciting
than building one
at a time that I'm really drawn to that
as this outlet for having huge positive
impact on the world one manifestation of
that for me has been asana which I'll
tell you a little more about how this
started and how of all the things I
could work on this feels like the most
important thing given my particular
skill sets so when I was at both Google
and Facebook when i first started at
Google I had sort of this romanticized
notion of okay I'm a product manager I'd
had internships as an engineer I got a
product manager now I'm gonna spend my
time constructing a vision and a bold a
bold way forward and being all these
strategy meetings and thinking at this
high level abstraction I was very wrong
I was spending literally ninety percent
of my time on the friction and overhead
of coordination making sure that the
left hand what the right hand was doing
making sure that you know running the
status meetings making sure that when
this got completed the next person knew
their part was ready and I was like okay
well maybe that's just how pming is but
what was more tragic was that individual
engineers individual designers these
people who were some of the world's best
at what they did that they were spending
just you know 60 huge percents of their
time not not doing work not doing the
thing they were passionate about but
doing work of that work right reading
emails writing emails I don't know how
much you guys experience this right now
but if you've been in business right
notting yeah you've been in any sort of
business context you know this just
consumes huge huge percentages of your
day it's amazing people just almost
accept this as the reality of how it has
to be and at first I was like I must be
doing something wrong there must be
better tools so i tried all the
different software all the different
project management methodologies
everything i could think of that was on
the market and it still just felt like
we were going so slowly relative to sort
of what it might feel like if we were
telepathic we all knew exactly what each
other was doing and thinking what was
more important how much better it would
be and so while i was at Google I
actually built sort of this small
internal project management system that
actually had like a thousand people by
the time I left and when I went to
Facebook I thought I had problems I
person who recruited me Dustin who was
the vp of engineering
the time he had problems just so much
worse he had like 20 managers who
reported to him and they each had 20
reports under them so he he literally
just couldn't figure out what was going
on in his own company let alone steer
the ship as he wanted to as a leader and
so he and I just started hanging out to
like three in the morning every night
there's kind of fantasizing okay what
would the ultimate solution to this
problem look like if we could build
anything like what would the software
look like that would get us basically as
close to this asymptote of telepathy as
we can imagine and Dustin being a doer
more than a dreamer at some point was
like all right I'm just gonna start
building this thing so he was being vp
by day and writing this the software on
the side and this thing took off so much
in the company that eventually he
stepped down from VP just to be an
individual contributor on this tool set
because he found that was more leverage
as a way to help the company than
running the engineering org and the more
we got into is the more we just like saw
the impact on our daily lives like the
number of meetings i was in drop
dramatically then over emails i had
dropped dramatically the speed at which
we were going increased dramatically and
at some point we just stopped and we we
realized like this is not a problem
that's unique to facebook or unique to
google or unique to tech to tech as a
whole this is a problem of all of
humanity because basically all human
endeavor so whether you're talking about
starting a small company or a fortune
500 company or a non-profit or an art
project or a government but basically
everything that we do as a species we do
in teams we come together we align our
energy in a common direction towards
some common vision and execute it
together you know hopefully harmoniously
and hopefully in sync that's the idea
it's amazing how much progress we've
made given you know historically how
limited our tools were for coordinating
our collective action and obviously
email helps a lot but email has become
we have really reached the limits of
what email is capable of and so the idea
there could be something better was just
so enticing Gus and to see there
actually was something better was so
amazing that even though we loved
Facebook and that was obviously a super
leveraged place to be and
able to create impact with somebody
realized this was a Facebook sized
opportunity this was just something that
was so profoundly profound its ability
to change the world because what if you
could take every single project and
accelerate it by ten percent or twenty
percent or double its effectiveness I
mean the kinds of things were capable of
doing today relatively the kinds of
things we were capable before email or
the cell phone or the Telegraph these
sorts of communication technologies just
keep taking you to the next level and so
you know I make enterprise software for
a living which it first sounds very
boring but the vision here and what's so
enticing to me is that it well I'll give
you three quick examples and then give
the abstraction so for example there's a
company emerald therapeutics that's
literally working on curing cancer and
they have I don't really understand what
they do all in white lab coats but
they're they're a bunch of people with
all these interconnected moving parts
working on this really complex chemistry
process and they said that the impact
that asana had on their ability to to
work together and collaborate and move
forward we just enabled whole groups of
people to start working on this problem
who couldn't before because they were
stuck doing middle management so you
know the idea of literally accelerating
the curing of cancer through this
technological infrastructure and
similarly there's this NGO naya health
that's working on bringing healthcare to
Nepal's rural poor so they have hundreds
of people across two continents working
on this complex operation and they just
described how the impact that asana has
had on both the quantity and the quality
of care they can provide it's been
mind-blowing so those are just two
examples either of which would have been
such a great thing to devote myself to
and so the idea that we can build that
sort of infrastructure layer or that
helps everyone at the same time is just
a super exciting way to to think about
this sort of vision even bigger than
that though even bigger than helping
individual fortune 500 companies or
individual teams be able to work
together I think what's really most
exciting about this vision in the long
term and a sauna alone won't do it but
the really the bigger vision for this is
imagine if all of humanity could
coordinate its collective action
seamlessly without effort as
if all of us could work together toward
a single common goal a single project
and I think one way to think about this
is that let's step back and put this in
an even more perspective at this point
the universe is 14 billion years old so
for the vast majority of that time it
was basically just some rocks and some
stars hanging out in empty space and
over a very very recent time slice of
that we've had this big change where
there's all this complexity that's
arisen on planet earth and within an
even smaller times less of that we have
the evolution of consciousness as we
know it and within you know 200 years
ago we were wiping our asses with bark
right like technology again putting some
context of seven builder 14 billion
years and so now we are at this point
where we have we're on this fascinating
cusp for all of a sudden we're empowered
with all this technology in a totally
totally unprecedented way and strangely
it seems that we're on this sort of cusp
where there's two paths that both to be
seem equally likely you on the one hand
have the path of that you know I we want
to go into details but between global
warming and the certain biological
warfare and just like a bunch of
different problems that we global
catastrophic risks we're at this point
where I mean the global warming science
is you know whether it's 30 years or 300
years we are on an exponentially
increasing trajectory we are going to
consume all the resources and very
likely leave the earth in a much less
pleasant state than the one we're
enjoying today that's basically just
rampant shortsightedness and a ram an
inability to come together and solve
global problems because everyone is
focused on their individual desires
there's an alternative world which is if
we are able to solve those problems if
we are able to come together to
coordinate our collective action to see
ourselves not as a bunch of individuals
vying for what is on our own interest
but to instead think about the we as a
whole to identify with humanity's
interest as a whole which I also think
will lead to more individual human
happiness if we're able to come together
and see us as basically part of one big
project not a series of little teams
keeping with each other but a single
company working for a single ends
instead we could break through instead
of art of the complexity of earth
looking like this exponential trajectory
and then kaput it could instead keep
going we could manage to make the world
sustainable to make our consumption
sustainable to find new ways to do
things like you solve the sort of
ridiculous problem we have that we have
enough food to feed everyone but it's
not evenly distributed and to allow
everyone to have the resources they need
to contribute to the world and the way
they should be capable of and instead to
continue on this exponential trajectory
in a world of abundance in a world we're
all exploring our creative possibilities
and our creative potential so we really
are in this place where we can choose
either of these worlds and it really is
a question of do we have the will to
come together and see ourselves and
align our interests together as a single
species and we have these the actual
tools and skills and technology in order
to be able to effectively coordinate
that will even if we all share so for
the rest of the talk I want to talk
about so asana is one of these sorts of
visions that I think fits into this what
I call the one project the single human
project for global thriving we are all
coming together and all contributing our
particular unique skills to this grand
tapestry of creation and doing something
great in the world but there are all
sorts of other pieces of this there are
going to be contributing in order to in
order you know and it's everything from
things that sound fill in topic like
health care but I would even put
something like you know uber in this
category of or lift of look lifting even
more so in terms of enabling car sharing
to has to have fewer cars on the roads
in general so as you go out into the
world I just encourage you and I would
hope that rather than focusing on how do
I get as much money as possible how do I
get as much accolades as possible how do
I collect as much resources that for
myself as I can which both seems to be a
fool's errand in terms of happiness and
it misses out on the opportunity to
contribute to this giant opportunity
that we have in front of us to make the
world really much more exciting place
than the caput scenario I wanted to give
you guys some advice or things that have
at least
been working for me at the level of
values at the level of leadership
tactics and at the level of managing
your psychology in order to be able to
lead these sorts of big ambitious
visions that can be on a day-to-day
basis very very rough on the psyche this
stuff is not easy so the values is
actually even a concept as a whole that
are thinking about values is so
important to a company success is
something I really picked up from Tina
and Tom and I just hadn't really
occurred to me before being being at
Stanford but it has turned out to be so
important and values are specifically
not just things you sort of put on the
list of onboarding materials that you
give to new hires and then never mention
again these are the things you actually
repeatedly come back to and our words
for us that are actually used like
almost on an hourly basis inside
meetings because they are really deeply
embedded in the culture I sometimes take
it for granted and then someone who
recently joined will be like never
realized that one can talk about ego
lessness or mindfulness so much and we
have like we have lots of different
values and a lot of them are more
standard so I wanted to just focus on a
few that i think are a little more
unusual for a company to have so the
first one is mindfulness so what i mean
by that is knowing what you're doing
sounds very obvious but it's amazing how
uncommon a value that is for people to
really be always focused on what what do
we know about what we're doing and to
reflect clearly and deeply on is this
what we want to be doing is this aligned
with our values are there other things
we should be doing instead so I'll give
you a couple examples of a very concrete
rituals that we use in order to be more
mindful so one is every other week we
have an all hands as a tgif and everyone
goes around the room and says and we're
still small enough we can do this
everyone says one thing that they're
excited about about the company and one
thing one area where they think we could
be spending more attention wear
something warrants more thought which is
interestingly phrase it's not one thing
you think we're doing badly oh and think
we do you think we're doing well and as
Tina taught me problems are just
opportunities so
what is the opportunity for us to be
putting more attention on something and
what's so cool about this process is a
few things one is the energy that you
accumulate going around the room and
everyone's saying what they're excited
about actually makes everyone first of
all know to do more of that and it
celebrates it and by the end of the
meeting we typically are kind of on this
high together if like wow we really are
doing something really exciting or
emboldened to continue the project on
the things we can be paying more
attention to what's so great about that
is you never end up in this situation as
I've seen before where a problem
Fester's for six months and everyone's
kind of thinking about in the back of
their head but they're not sure if
they're alone they're not sure if it's
okay to voice it to their peers or to
management and then it's only six months
later that it's not like festered but
it's gotten out of control and it's hard
so the fact that on the two you know at
least a bi-weekly basis where we're
going through and surfacing what people
think we should spend more attention on
means we just don't get we don't get
stuck with those things everyone's very
open and honest and contributing what
could we be doing better and it's
actually gone to the point where now we
go around the room everyone says
something they're excited about but only
a few people sometimes no one says
something that could use improvement
because we've just addressed each thing
so systematically that we just every
time one of us has the company just gets
a little bit better a little bit better
a related process is five wise which I
don't know how many you've heard of this
it's actually third part of the lean
startup program was originally at Toyota
that they pioneered this but let's say
that the site crashes or we have a PR
snafu or just something happens that we
really wish would never happen again we
do this exercise called five wives where
we ask okay well why did the site go
down and it's like well the we ran out
of memory okay well why do we run out of
memory well there wasn't code in place
to check that that edge condition well
why wasn't there code in place and you
just keep going until I time your fifth
why you might be at something like
because we don't sufficiently emphasize
test-driven development in our
engineering onboarding process right
that's the less interesting part the
more interesting part is you then say
for each of those wise what is a
proportionate response that we can take
in order to help ameliorate this and
make sure this
sort of thing doesn't happen again you
said I don't want to go overboard but
you want it but you typically want to do
something to help make sure that this
this get is better in the future and so
again it's this process whereby taking
the time it doesn't take that long but
by taking the time to stop and reflect
and think we just have very an extremely
stable product despite the fact we push
code every day and that's just one
example just throughout the company and
the marketing team all over the company
we run this process to get a little bit
better and so you know if every day you
get one percent better as a company
through this sort of technique you know
exponentially by the end of the year
you'll be 40 x better another value is
balance um I'm actually amazed how this
doesn't come out more often for more
people because what we've experienced is
that over and over again almost you know
every time you're faced with a decision
which is all the time there's typically
two different extremes you could take we
could go all the way to this extreme or
you go all the way to this extreme and
as a leader it's super tempting to want
to say let's do one of these because by
doing so you can you're very clear
there's a lot of clarity you can tell
your reports this is exactly the
trajectory that we're taking but in
general the extremes are really bad
extremes lead to all these negative
consequences and the solution isn't
necessarily even to find a compromise
that kind of gets you half of the
benefits of one and half of the benefits
to the other ideally you want to find a
middle way that actually transcends the
negatives of both of these things so
I'll give you a couple examples on this
typically when you're doing any product
decision there's a question of should we
do this the right way or should we do
this the fast way this comes up in
product this comes with an engineering
I'm it comes up in everything right you
could and and this is a great example
where either extreme is clearly terrible
if you spend all your time if you spend
an unbounded amount of time making
things perfect before you ever ship the
market will pass you by and you by the
time you're ready to launch the someone
else will have taken that market share
from you but on the other end if you
just throw spaghetti at the wall and
hope to see what sticks and maybe it'll
work maybe it won't then you'll really
tarnish your brand because people will
know that this is not a quality brand
that we can actually rely upon so for us
the middle way here is we call pragmatic
craftsmanship which is to say the really
is no intellectual answer to how to make
this to how to make this call but
instead we hire people who have really
really good judgment as in like for
example on the engineering side
technical chops are you know that that's
a myth that's the minimum bar or that
that's not that's not even at the
minimum bar it's not just the technical
ability it's that sort of wisdom that
comes from really deeply understanding
should I take more time in this case or
should I take a look take less time in
this case it's really valuing that and
empowering people to think about that is
really important to us another good
example of this is like work you know
work-life balance which I think often
has this meaning of like oh don't worry
too much about work but I mean in a
slightly different way of like there
there are people who work you know say
40 hours a week and what I find it for
myself as that wouldn't be enough time
to get done all the things i want to get
done but sometimes i try working 60
hours a week for week after week after
week and i find i get super diminishing
returns in terms of i'm actually just
burning myself out by week five and i'm
not getting as much done as I would if I
were spending less time so instead we
invest both in sort of again the inhale
and the exhale taking the time to you're
working really hard on the exhale but
then taking the time to replenish on the
inhale and so you know that takes all
sorts of forms including like offering
yoga at the company or offering really
delicious free food or having social
events together and then the third and
last value that I'll talk about here is
radical transparency so I'll give you a
couple examples of this so when we have
board meetings at the end of every board
meeting first of all sometimes someone
from the company has just invited to
come to the board meeting who isn't on
the board just as I can actually
participate and enjoy the process and
learn from it but eat but regardless we
always take really copious notes and
then send those notes out to the entire
company after the fact we have weekly
planning meeting that includes me Dustin
our head of engineering and our head of
business and there are certainly some
things like HR issues where it's not our
thought our prerogative to share that
with the whole company how kind of share
salaries that's really their personal
information to share but for almost
everything else again we take copious
notes send those notes out to everyone
in the company and sometimes it starts a
dialogue where people like actually you
know I think
decision you made you know you should
consider this other option sometimes we
you know either engage in dialogue or
sometimes just say we can't respond
every single thing but for the most part
that creates this really collaborative
process where people can have a lot of
trust that we're thinking about the
right things and making the right
decisions and so the effect of that is
you know one trust and I think just the
sort of has a lot of value kind of in
and of itself I think one of the coolest
things that you get from this kind of
radical transparency is that it means
that people are empowered with enough
knowledge that they don't have to be
micromanaged and told this is exactly
what you should do and this is exactly
how you should do your job you couldn't
even micromanage people at the level of
detail required like even when you're
writing an individual if statement or
making an individual decision about some
caching scheme or certainly all the time
in little product design details there's
there's understanding the bigger picture
understanding who is the customer how we
trying to serve them what are the market
conditions were under what are the ways
in which we're trying to advance our
brand can go down to the tiniest little
decisions and so by focusing more on
providing people with context about
their work context about the overall
goals of the company context around our
values and how we think it's good to
make decisions rather than trying to
control people's actions and control
people's decisions we find that leads to
them being able to be much more
effective and not surprisingly it means
we can hire people who are much more
seasoned and senior who are excited
about who are more excited about
contributing in a way that's the
response the fact that they are appears
in fact I lied there's a fourth I and
that's the Portland company as
collective of peers we we make a point I
think it one thing to point out is that
I think in the last maybe ten years or
so this is a pretty recent phenomenon
even in Silicon Valley maybe even five
years there's been this real
fetishization of entrepreneurship in
fact yes you have people like Paul
Graham who are bordering on telling
people you're a chump if you go work for
another company I think this is really
ludicrous the sometimes the most
leverage way to impact things is to
start your own project but a lot of the
times they're just so many great ideas
out there the opportunity to play a big
role in making those things a reality is
just as interesting and we're all
visionaries if we have environments
allow us to come together in cloud
rate and I can see how people have come
to this conclusion because traditional
companies are running this way where
there's a really strong to class
structure where you have the visionaries
on top making all the decisions and
there sometimes they're peons going on
out in executing but we have the
privilege of we're able to hire there's
extraordinary people who definitely
could be running their own companies but
instead we've come together and created
this kind of super group and so one
example of a practice we use to try to
respect us as a company of peers is
roadmap week so every basically quarter
we divide them into episodes instead of
quarters which are kind of an episode of
this is what we want to accomplish in
the next few months or so at the end of
each of these episodes we have a roadmap
week where the whole company more or
less stops doing normal work and instead
everyone is in a bunch of different
committees so you just have one week of
meetings all day over all week with nice
about this of course is that we have a
lot fewer meetings during the rest of
the quarter so it's again this such a
rhythm of concentrated meetings and then
concentrated in fewer meetings and in
these committee meetings will have a
committee about mobile and our mobile
strategy will have the committee about
our values will have a committee about
how we're going to expand the design
team committee about the recruiting team
and sometimes these committees consist
of the people that you would expect of
sometimes they consist of people who are
you know someone in the customer support
team who's read all the mobile
complaints and so wants to be in that
meetings that can voice the view the
voice of the customer and those
committees are given again a lot of
context ahead of time on over all values
and how we kind of broadly see something
like mobile fitting in with our strategy
but it's up to the committee to reflect
on where are we now where could we be
going what are the different options
what are the pros and cons of those
different options given those pros and
cons what is our evaluation of how we
should step forward what you know who
are the right people to work on this
what are our requirements what resources
do we need and they just put forth this
plan for the next quarter for what we
should do sometimes there'll be you know
all the committee's will have more work
than we could possibly do so we have to
sort of cut things a little bit but in
general those committees are not you
know really are making the decision in
theory Dustin or I could override them
and say no no you've missed the
mark entirely we should do the other
thing but that's never actually happened
we really trust people to just make the
right decisions collect input from the
right people within the company and then
we go forward with those as the plans of
record so that's I think a much better
situation for everyone moving on to
tactics relating seems big visions and
one thing about tactics just to say
broadly is that again as you just think
about your company constantly taking the
time to reflect on what are things we
could be doing just a little bit better
a little bit better means that these
institutional processes bacon and over
time you just get much much better so
these are just we have tons of different
things like this but here just a couple
that we're surprising to me in their
simplicity and how well they work so one
is directly responsible individuals
basically for any single thing in the
company whether it's something as big as
our security or something as small as
fixing this bug there's always exactly
one person not zero not to one person
who is the DRI which is a term we
actually took from Apple and they may
have a huge team behind them that's
that's helping them to execute that work
but there's always someone who is
accountable and who and who owns that
particular thing and that has this great
benefit of its know it's always clear
who has the ball who's driving this
forward this works really well with the
company calendar and this is again a
great example of balance where I think
there's I've always been stuck in the
past between these two leadership styles
where you know you want to get a lot
done you want to have accountability you
want to make sure that people do the
things they're going that they commit to
and it's always felt like well there's a
sort of soft leadership style where
you're like okay guys let's let's all
work together to make this happen oh you
missed your deadline okay and then the
other style which is the hard-driving
you know oh you know yell at people tell
them that they screwed up and neither of
these is appealing to me and so what
we've done instead is is this company
calendar which is a really simple
process where every Tuesday this is our
only other all hands meeting everyone
comes together we go around then every
every team leader effectively or
sometimes people on their teams will
will update the calendar and say here is
a milestone that I commit to and they
say this in front of the whole company
so to all their peers not to us but to
their peers they say by this state I'm
going to ship this thing or I'm going to
achieve this internal milestone and then
we also go through when people say we go
through the past and we say what are the
things that we were good we committed to
over the last week since last Tuesday
and people just go around the room and
generally say I said that on Thursday I
was three weeks ago i said on thursday
i'm going to ship this thing and on
thursday it shipped and there's a whole
round of applause and everyone's very
excited and we support each other and
it's great that a ninety percent of time
that really is what happens people feel
this strong sense of communal pressure
not coming from me I just set the
process but coming from the team as a
whole and that sort of camaraderie of
you know I worked we worked really hard
to make this happen and when you know
you have a DRI who has four people
working with them before people are
working late into the night not for me
or for Dustin but for the vision and for
the DRI who sort of put their name on
put themselves out there and said our
team is going to get this done and in
that rare those rare times when people
don't meet their debt when meet their
milestones we don't we don't scowl with
them we don't tell them you screwed up
we have them run a five wise process
they go through and they say why didn't
I meet this why did that happen why did
that happen they send out those notes to
the entire company and everyone gets to
communally learn and so we're just
getting better over time but accurately
predicting when those milestones will
actually be completed and being able to
execute them effectively she's been
really cool so would say it's a
judgment-free process that empowers
everyone to do their best work okay the
last section is about managing your own
psychology a couple of years ago I was
in what we were starting to grow the
company we hadn't even launched yet and
I was just starting to get
extraordinarily stressed I I felt like
the weight of the world on my shoulders
I was very attached to that this thing
succeed but was starting to doubt
whether I would be capable of it and it
was getting to the point where I was so
stressed that i would just like I was
coming into work for like
whole week and I would just stare at my
screen for a couple hours not do
anything at some point just be like well
I don't know I just can't handle this
anymore um it was around that time that
we had our series a witch Marc
Andreessen Ben Horowitz participated in
her and race car was participated and we
were out to dinner with them Dustin I
rest dinner with them a while after that
and I want I really respect Ben as a
mentor and so I wanted to get his advice
on this those a little intimidated to be
like I didn't want him to be like I just
gave you all this buddy and you're
telling me that you're scared of doing
the job I'm paying you to do um but
instead he just very matter-of-factly it
was like yes this is actually a good
thing for you to know the most important
part of being a leader is managing your
own psychology and proceeded to tell me
all these stories or times that he
struggled with this so just want to
finish by telling you a few things I
found really helpful all right I've to
mikes these things I found really
helpful in doing this um the first one
is one see how many people in the room
have experienced you know maybe every
day some sort of voice in your head that
sounds like it's your voice but it's
telling you you're doing things badly
for those of you without your hands
raised I think you're lying thank you
for this with your present pump I used
to have you are we're very far but I
find for almost everyone it's a natural
human State and yeah it sounds like you
used to experience this there is a voice
that is that is self-doubting and
judging and it's very easy to confuse
this voice for your self because
especially cuz it speaks in your own
voice but it's not it's sort of like
having an annoying judgmental
mate living in your head um you'll
notice this now that I pointed out and
every time that you hear that voice I so
I after doing tons of I don't not sure
what your path was I've done a ton of
meditation work and all sorts of things
and I still hear this voice but the
difference is that I now have a new
relationship to it I hear the voice I
say thank you I appreciate that you're
trying to be helpful you can keep
hanging out in my head that's totally
fine you kick your feet up make yourself
comfortable but that's not me and I make
decisions from a different place and so
I continue to act in the face of fear
even when those those things keep coming
up and telling me oh you're screwing
this up somewhat closely related Lee is
imposter syndrome have you ever had the
experience of finding yourself in a
group of people where you realize where
you thought to yourself oh all these
people clearly belong here I understand
why they're all here but it would I must
have gotten here by mistake this is a
confusion or worse you find yourself in
a leadership role we were like oh man
these people are about three seconds
away from realizing the emperor has no
clothes like I'm not what I'm doing they
should not be following me they should
just do a coup right now um has anyone
ever experiences appreciate your eyes um
what I have so far observed and with
psychology researchers reserves this is
pretty much a universal human phenomenon
at least in the Western world if not
globally but again I find it really cool
to recognize that so many so many of us
will project onto you but at least so
many of us experience this so regularly
because it's just an opportunity to
remember so many people feel this way
and it doesn't mean that you are doesn't
mean that you are an imposter in the
situation it's just a voice in your head
that's had some evolutionary purpose and
today's vestigial actually even in
writing these notes I had to chuckle
because I was like oh et al like I were
being part of that and all these smart
people would come with all this great
stuff to say you know I really
appreciate Tina for having the soft spot
for me that she let me slide in but
hopefully I was not an entirely
inappropriate guest for you and i think
is lastly equanimity
so again there are these two what seemed
like two extremes that are both pretty
unfortunate you kind of have the
stereotype of someone who very
lackadaisical doesn't really care isn't
really working very hard it's just kind
of getting by doesn't get a whole lot
done and then you have this other
stereotype of someone who is very
intensely engaged in their project and
passionate what they're doing and is
kind of with this little sense of stress
and fear all the time that you know
we've got to make this happen we got to
make this work both of these seem like
really unfortunate outcomes because the
latter the former you're not very
effective and the latter you get burned
out and eventually aren't very effective
either and so while this seems like a
contradiction at first what I've
discovered and I'm not saying it's easy
is that is willful intention with non
concern for results so what I mean by
that is on my best days I come to work
and I am fiery and passionate and so
excited like the universe is moving
through me to build and manifest this
vision into the world and I recognize
that it may not work out and if it
doesn't that's okay too the world will
go on my will go on I will be safe it'll
be fine I'll get over it now that
doesn't mean that I'm going to give up
if things were going very badly you know
and there's any chance we still might
succeed I will fight and fight and fight
to make that thing still work but if it
doesn't it doesn't so we've looked at
today and what would think I'm most
excited about you know we've looked at a
lot of different ways that you could
given given a very ambitious mission
ambitious vision work with a team of
people or even just be the leader of
yourself to have these different tools
and techniques and tactics to be able to
work more efficiently work more
effectively be able to achieve these
visions but the biggest thing i think
that's interesting here is that I just
really hope that you guys may be already
are or would like to join this sort of
global cause this species level cause
that is allows you the opportunity
participate in something that is just
much much bigger than yourself we are
today writing the story of human history
this is not a foregone conclusion there
is not manifest destiny here we
are the actual people who are going to
decide whether we go to the caput
scenario or whether we take off and I'm
a more sand on smaller scale just what
the future holds for us the people we
love and for the whole of the human race
and you know a hundred years ago or
something thinking at that level would
have sounded almost crazy because who
could have that much impact but today we
just have countless examples that people
really can start projects in their dorm
rooms and do things that have massive
world-shaking impact on the world and
and you guys are those people I mean
this is truly a cliche but like the you
guys are the leaders of tomorrow I mean
III know I was sitting here 10 years ago
and i know tons of people who were
sitting here 10 years ago who are doing
bigger things than I am are doing you
know huge things there are real movers
and shakers in the world you obviously
will be the next generation of that and
so the opportunity to devote all of that
power all that time you spent investing
in your skills and intellect and human
capacities the choices of whether to
invest that in something that is
something that you know will make make
make some money or that will have some
short-term gain versus the opportunity
to find something in the intersection of
your deepest passion and the possibility
for having a huge positive impact on the
world just so exciting and the primary
reason I came here today to want to
share this stuff with you so thank you
yeah and we have 10 minutes for
questions so I'm really wonderfully
surprised because I don't see nearly
enough but the principles of you're
talking about here I believe are at the
heart of creating powerful feeds there's
a sauna looking to actually incorporate
this into tools and scale the concept of
letting teams be able to come strapped
oh yes I mean at every level of
abstraction I mean so the question was
can we it is a sauna incorporate these
sorts of abstract principles into the
product design and that's certainly one
of the most exciting things about
working on infrastructure for teams is
that you know I could give talks like
this but only a finite number of people
are going to hear me whereas if we can
build software that everyone on earth is
using I mean it's you know as an example
like the DRI concept that that's
something where asana presents itself
primarily as a task list for your team
and every single task has one assignee
we could have easily at a technical
level made it so that multiple people
could be assigned to a task because we
have this value around if if two people
are assigned no one's assigned no one's
really responsible there's always one
assign it you can demarcate that other
people are helping out but they're the
person in charge and so or another thing
is we just added a like button esque
feature called heart so you're using
yeah um there's again designed to sort
of like engage people in remembering
that it's not just this isn't just work
that there's there's feeling and emotion
here and in particular to allow people
to you know like was about 11 but one
button 1-click affirmation this the
asana heart button is about one click
one click gratitude one click
recognition because it's a basic human
thing that we all want to be you know
appreciated for our hard work and this
is an opportunity to do that so I could
literally sit here for like four hours
and show you every single feature and
how each one was mindful II considered
in the context of how do we want the
world to be and as long as a flexible
tool so if you want to run your company
in a top-down hierarchical manner asana
supports that totally fine but it also
supports that maybe maybe the structure
might start that way it makes it very
natural start transitioning into
or of a flat structure where people are
if not just managers assigning things to
reports but everyone assigning things to
everyone else and everyone participating
in that planning process going to make
the claim of the research internet and
all making a splash my thing wake up see
any do you see of flip happening where
we put this oneness as opposed to this
constant expansion to manage yeah well
there's there's multiple expansions into
infinity but but yeah so the question
isn't technology making us less mindful
in a bunch of ways I think that it's
definitely true it is definitely the
double-edged sword of like wandering
around with a phone that I have accessed
all this information but it's so
tempting to me that I keep accessing it
I think there's a number of solutions to
this problem one is I really think we
just have to i think that the common
success metric that companies use in
order to determine whether they're doing
the right thing is something like page
views or something like minutes spent on
the site and i think they do that not
out of a knot of malice particularly but
because it's just the easiest thing to
measure its it seems like well surely
that is our success metric and yet I
would be much happier to have a product
that people were spending you know five
minutes on per day instead of 20 minutes
on per day if those five minutes were
making them happier in fact that would
be much much better because it means
they can get back to their lives an
ideal world to would spend zero minutes
sana sana it would feel more like you
know the kind of just just as there's
you know telepathy between my hands in a
way that feels effortless and that's
what allows me to do complex things or
play a guitar it'd be great if it were
effortless for us to coordinate our
collective action among the different
nodes that are different people and so
we don't use that kind of time on site
as a success metric moving to a world
where you instead think about the impact
and as a product designer think what am
I actually trying to accomplish in the
world not just how much are people
engaging with this product right now is
something that I think is a mental shift
in values that is desperately needed in
our industry and part of why i'm now
going around preaching this
given the wide array of black ways you
can use a sauna like it's my reflections
of video others is it how do you go
about prioritizing obviously new
features but also communicating the
point and a good harvest maybe of
enterprise clients who might not be as
familiar with the sauna yeah yeah so
giving this on his flexibility because
asana ends up being just useful for a
huge different array of things when we
use it for everything from yeah managing
our bugs lists managing what snacks we
want for the kitchen imagine meeting
notes managing our applicant tracking
pipelines to managing our press
everything so how do you explain that
and how do you prioritize given all
those use cases the way the way that we
explain it it is definitely a challenge
I mean it's so much more convenient when
you can have a product like Google Docs
or it's like its word for the web or
Dropbox which is like if your file
system in the cloud and the if those are
really important products to build and
it's really nice that it works out to be
that simple asana just ends up not
having that simple a value proposition
it's more like invest in this and you
will become more efficient and we mostly
it's just we spend a lot of time
thinking about it we spend a lot of time
specializing like different audiences
that we're talking to this kind of
person we want to show them this message
kind of this kind of person where I show
them that message we focus on sort of
the effects rather than the individual
pieces like you know you go to the
website and it says do great things and
has inspiring inspiring stories people
have been successful with the product
and then starts to introduce you to the
individual features but I mean it's
definitely just a fascinating challenge
working on something that isn't
something that already exists with a
slight tweak and and I think with what's
been most successful so far is just the
product is like your nephew who loved
the product that they evangelize it and
I spread it to their friends and we
aren't we actually think that is the
primary for all the work we've done on
like viral growth mechanics we actually
think that word of mouth and love is the
primary driver right now and you can
like do a Twitter search for asana love
and like every 30 minutes there's a
there's a tweet about it in terms of
prioritization of features yeah a son
also just has this huge surface area you
could work on so many different
components of it and there we do a a
mindful process of a giant list in the
south
of all things we could work on we
collect input from different people in
the company about what they'd like to
see we collect input from the customer
support team about what they're hearing
the most requests for we do we serve a
user's inside the product every six
weeks where we asked them like how much
are you enjoying this like what would
you like to see changed talk to the
sales team about what they're hearing
from our bigger customers and then just
use balance and judgments to try to
integrate that into into a list combined
with like a vision of you know there's
all these different paces we want to
expand what's the next next big step and
another big input to that frankly is
just enter our own energy and our own
enthusiasm you can take that to an
extreme to balance that against the
other variables but a lot of times it
just it feels right to do this next
thing and we're willing to trust that
got a lot of questions and Facebook
you're kind of blown at metric might
have been say session time Lana say what
the only measure right it might have
been a ventric that scary though romance
and other things too but you're talking
what I saw that you want to enable
people how did you personally maybe with
Dustin of all of your psychology to say
this is what we care about and how did
you go and measure my cuz it's a very
different shift in psychology what you
careful have we evolve our supposed to
care about compared to how are we
getting people spend more time on these
pronouns in making your connections yeah
um and then second question was how do
we measure that so yeah yeah get into
the mold yourself um I'm not sure what a
little abstraction to them for but to be
perfectly honest I've spent most every
day of the last like five years either
meditating or doing yoga and I've spent
like I once spent a week sitting in the
forest alone fasting and just like
meditating for 16 hours a day I've just
like done a bunch of work in the
direction of really quieting my mind and
seeing once all the distractions are
gone who's left like what what is my
actual essence as a person after all the
kind of noise that
rounds my day to day obligations
disappears and as I've come deeper and
deeper into that sense of of quiet
things just become astoundingly clear
and I just have this overflowing sense
of love for the universe and my fellow
man and it just becomes very clear that
what I want to do is devote myself to
the service of others which then it
becomes very obvious well what's the
most leverage way I could help others is
by giving them the tools to enable them
to be more effective at fulfilling their
particular missions and capabilities in
the world
you